Solo queda un camino que permite entrar
y salir de la ciudad por el momento lo
utilizan principalmente vehículos
blindados y ambulancias ucranianas pero
es una ruta que los rusos están tratando
de acortar en el terreno las tropas
ucranianas son pesimistas sobre la
situación
la situación es muy difícil para
nosotros los rusos están cercando vacmut
para descansar los soldados se refugian
bajo tierra en este sótano de la ciudad
las tropas rotan entre el campo de
batalla y la seguridad es un espacio
pequeño para los cientos de hombres que
este alberga sus rostros están marcados
por el agotamiento y la ansiedad algunos
están durmiendo mientras otros están
preparando su salida de regreso al
frente de batalla
los rusos son tan numerosos que parecen
hormigas que avanzan mientras nos
empujan hacia atrás Es difícil mantener
vivos a nuestros soldados y aguantarse
psicológicamente
el equipo médico evacuar los soldados
heridos y muertos todos los días un
trabajo que pasa factura
ayudar a los soldados heridos es lo más
difícil psicológicamente pero lo peor es
cuando ya no estás en el frente cuando
estás aquí y tienes tiempo para
reflexionar es un infierno
los soldados descansan durante 24 horas
antes de regresar al combate las fuerzas
ucranianas se enfrentan al fuego ruso
desde múltiples lados a medida que sus
tropas avanzan desde el norte el sur y
el este estas imágenes filmadas en las
calles de bakwood muestran que la ciudad
ahora es una zona de guerra pero a pesar
de la creciente presión rusa Ucrania no
tiene planes de entregar bakmut sin
luchar